to make it a two-possession game and a
four-point lead and that's what it is
then you see him stagger back so the
gate isn't right initially I think it's
a story more for what what it responds
to post post game
Davis trying to post up Schroeder calls
his own number missed the layup tipped
up Davis with the rebound slaps it home
and sets it with his chest
Davis guarded by Luca got a size
advantage and there it is that was an
easy fall Anthony Davis with the easy
Deuce there's this man been killing
people Luca not good enough defensively
to fade on point
because this man been killing people
Luca not good enough defensively the
fade on point
asking you shall receive Anthony Davis's
fingerprints have been all over this
game started on the defensive end things
changed when the Lakers got busy
defensively A.D all over it and then he
starts putting the hurt on you on the
offensive blast oh Luca couldn't get the
inbound pass and the